- We are in New York City,
the birthplace of roasting.
They sit around and bust
each other's balls anyway.
So the fact that we're
gonna have an actual night
dedicated to that is really
big for Roast Battle.
- I think it's good to
always respect your opponent.
- That voice, it's
like a police siren.
It's loud, it's irritating,
and it's mostly used
to chase black man.
So many black comics
have been inside you,
your underwear should
say Kevin Hart Presents.
(laughs)
- Wow.
- No!
- There's probably like a
mutual respect for each other
cause we're both very honest.
Two years ago, she was axed
from Last Comic Standing
and last year she was asked to
leave an Old Country Buffet.
(audience laughs)
That's a great joke.
(laughs)
- His entire act is gonna
be how fat, how black I am.
He's never gonna mention once
that my clit is
bigger than his dick.
(audience cheers)
- It was like
beautiful, you know.
It was wordplay, it was
racism, it's everything I like.
(laughs)
- You're battling Mike Lawrence.
He's kinda like a
teacher to you, right?
- No, did he said that?
(laughs)
He's just a retarded
guy I hang out with.
A lot of people think he's like
one of the best in the
city, if not the best.
So yeah, I'm excited
to battle him.
At least I know my dad's
watching this from heaven.
Your dad won't even
watch you on Seth Meyers.
(laughs)
Fucking dude.
(air horn blows)
- I've had to think
about Scott Chaplain
in the last two weeks.
I've fucked my wife and said,
"Did you like that,
Scott Chaplain?"
Scott's sister is a stripper.
(audience laughs)
She's really ashamed of it so
in order to stay anonymous,
she uses the stage
name, Scott Chaplain.
(audience laughs)
- Wow, oh my God.
- We've probably
got the best comics
that we're gonna
have on the show
and it's in the biggest
city in the world.
So, we're really
excited about it.
- It's family entertainment
at its fucking worst.
(laughs)